hey guys what's going on welcome to make
a bit uh yeah Peter Brown here with
Maxwell McGee howdy folks we're doing
playing strider to today Capcom sequel
to the original arcade hit okay i'll
call it sort of in celebration of the
release of the new strider yeah it seems
just fitting that we would do that yeah
I've got a bit of a cold but I'm going
to we're gonna do it anyway try some of
my energy you're almost there Peter it's
a little bit more this takes place two
thousand years after the original
striker oh well of course it does I
let's try just dancing oh so close it's
a one foot behind the other design ready
to go this plays like almost identical
like a hybrid of the original Strider
everyone what one thing i noticed pretty
much right away is that you cannot you
can't move his fabulous in moving stuff
like walk forward and sad like you can
in the new turn oh you totally dress oh
my my history with stridor is rather
shameful I only I was only ever first
introduced to the character and he I
guess would had to be the original
marvel vs capcom city was known as
playable characters in control in that
game and for the longest time I thought
Strider is actually some sort of
Canadian superhero because I guess it's
like the low res you know standard def
television I had at the time you look at
the little uh I don't know the kanji
that shredder has on his uniform and if
you sort of squint your eyes and it's
not real highlights it kind of looks
like the Maple Leafs like a red maple
leaf so for the longest I was like is he
supposed to be Canadian ninjas but then
like all the other Asian influences to
his characters I didn't make any sense I
didn't know how it was supposed to tie
together with the Canadian team at all I
was very I would love to hear your
alternate universe okay alter do that
makes sense Ryder is he's a hero of the
great white north the police is a food
sisters oh wow it's just 200 in this
game yep oh man this is pretty awesome
what's the point how do you see this is
something the new Strider stabbing this
sadly lacks like it the Boosters the
fights are in there and there's some of
my favorite parts of the new Strider
game but you're not fighting them on top
of flying cars in a futuristic city
riders coming he's from like this
legendary clan of ninjas he's super fast
he's got this crazy sword what am I
gonna do horse horse horses are fast
he's like a horse factory like n right
inside this box bc any bread words oh oh
oh what was that Peter Oh No what was
that for class I think you just got walk
son thanks very voice you're tired I
know you do like you wouldn't feel the
need to yell every single time but then
again Strider is a man of few words did
he say anything yeah he does in the new
game I think he has about six lines of
dialogue including including her hair
all those different grounds
this is just like we're the game well at
this moment gonna take a break from the
console or if you'll run around this
circle but Peter look be going to circle
and in the background becomes the
foreground yeah bite herzog I really
want to fill is there such a thing
Glyn's know you don't but I don't be a
monster okay stay out of the shot stay
out of the shop there he goes okay
you're ruining the shot Frank get out of
here stood here wait where we go also
let's resurrect a mammoth and make an
acai point and give him robot leg see
this is so good this is so good new
Strider does not have reincarnated half
cyborg Willis can you get behind them to
stab them in video and the leg and it's
what also in the butt oh you just gonna
do it for the same is sort of challenge
hard mode that you may be okay so you do
just kind of stand and stab a whole lot
I know I know this game is so weird whoa
researchers that's a walrus in a wolf
well they where we sir just like two
seconds and then you ran in the room and
they were like oh no time to hook out
Thunder whoa I bet the guy got the war
drew the walrus draw it's really dumb it
was like Larry you got to turn into the
sweet like saber-tooth wolf what
happened man she's like well we only had
enough you know ancient sabre wolf serum
for one saberwolf so I kind of had to
make do with what was lying around and
got Warren you know we still had a lot
of extra wall or serum cuz nobody
nobody's really into being a walrus
these days the experiment area yeah so
this their way you know
what they tell you when you're trying to
head over to the secret base now like
where's the experiment area like you see
the giant cucumber with the crab claws
sticking out of it and all the lasers
also you know you've gotten come where
you probably with these they don't like
to mention the teeth I'm trying you know
you weren't freak people out well
striders already bested our best tanks
and vessels up dude on the horse you
know you bested a guy with the ax like
what do we do well you know we stood you
know Larry down in research don't wants
to do that giant cucumber with klappa
idea Electra might as well let him give
it a shot sort of run out of good ideas
there is like in his office right about
to take his own right yeah just phone
call comes like oh they finally did it
they finally realized my genius giant
cucumber would see everything's coming
up Larry I just enjoy the view I know
this guy back here he's trying so hard
he was like you know you think that
would send at least one other person
besides me out here to try to stop the
few know the Strider he's killed like a
thousand of our people it's just me they
just send me squad leader leader its
first name squad last quick okay well
you know look just just figure it out
okay how does not know what to do oh hey
sorry I'm late okay see you later god
I'm just no help whatsoever now which
way is he gonna go yeah yeah
therapy
guys are the control rooms not like the
left the right is stuck I can't make him
go left tonight we'll just go up and
down maybe it'll work itself out see
know those guys had the right idea
they're like look straighter he's killed
all the robots he killed the Scarab II
he killed the minelayer we obviously
shouldn't be trying to fight him Wow
yeah just build a wall also he keeps
exploding and then just bring himself
back to life obviously we cannot
actually stop him we just need to impede
his progress really like these guys yeah
this is coming up just hammer the ball
just hammer the wall just get it in
place just get it into place I hope I
get to fight every single boss again a
needleless oh that would be so good God
you have a they're gonna hate dr wily
style room it was teleporters again this
is Capcom every single mom hey oh oh no
bad guys Strider you got biodesign son
en and you're fighting on top of the
crazy dragon saying oh this is really
good this is really good and look he's
got a twin sized door it's sort of so
much more sword than your swords
hear you guys fighting each I'm helping
I'm here to help don't worry Oh No nice
what am I seen here it's a UH where we
got like a fish that's got a flaming
tail caduceus attached to a statue which
is then attached to purple angel all
right I could do see it you know some
Grecian myth that was anything
yes master is a room wait okay well see
you later yes consistency minion and
then Strider straight up murdered this
dude here you to headquarters and we're
gonna have to build another moon mission
accomplished accomplished also i'm on
i'm kind of on top of an exploding thing
oh no wait it's all cool i'm back there
we go my shoulders are hella cold boo
it's cool Oh DNA hurry hurry go go go
we're gonna do I'm gonna do feel like it
should be lry for Larry Larry was really
the real hero and all there this is what
happens Larry come on you can do it all
da where Larry alright that's gonna be a
wrap whoo it's watching everybody
started to deal with my illness I'll be
back next week on top of the world one
hundred percent less ill yeah I will not
be dying on air yeah so once again this
is megabit tuning every friday at 11am
some axel McGee thank you for joining me
thank you for having me alright have a
nice weekend you guys see ya to care